[Music]
this is a great question i actually
called my wife and asked if she sent
this in
um she did not but she did give me her
answers and so these answers are
directly from my wife question is
how does your
first of all
i don't i don't even know if this is
true is this true the question is how
does your wife deal with your highs and
lows
and your stun gun energy that's not true
that's super true
do i have highs and lows i think i do
do you want
me to be nice or do you want to really
no we always said we would tell the
truth on this show yes you have highs
and lows really yes i thought i was
pretty like pretty like a walking xanax
not so much not in any way shape or form
do i have stun gun i do have that i do
have that i'm a lot i'm a lot okay so
here we go walking through this um
there's a couple of of good things to
talk about here
number one
i hear this on the road
and
things like man i wish my husband would
fill in the blink like you
or i wish my wife would ask me questions
like you
told this woman to ask her husband
questions i wish you would i wish my i
could be like right
so
i think it's important to know that like
living with me is hard and being married
to me is hard and i don't do that on
purpose um i just a lot i'm a lot
and so all the things like i read a lot
of books and i'm doing a lot of things
and i've got an intense morning routine
that there's that's one side of the
teeter-totter the other side of the
teeter-totters i'm a lot
and i get pretty focused on my routine
and i tend to read a book and i just
zone out i lose
consciousness i just i'm head out and so
um
it's my wife that
picks up a lot of that and or drives a
lot of that so the question how does
your wife deal with your highs and lows
and your stun gun energy
i think this applies across the board
anybody listening to this number one
nobody's perfect and i'm tough so
there's some good stuff and some tough
stuff right
so here's what her answers were number
one therapy that made me feel good
and really great friends and i will
caveat she's got some extraordinary
friends both locally and um nationally
friends she's had for a long long time
and newer friends that she meets with
regularly
and i don't get my feelings hurt when
she chooses to tell them things that i
wish she would tell me
i don't get my feelings hurt when she
has to go tell them that john really
isn't picking up the weight here or
struggling she has to process things in
our marriage with her friends i don't
get my feelings heard about that and i
used to
that's an important place for her and
it's not about me and whenever i get
people are making like i can't believe
you told his friends about that if
you're talking about intimate details of
your sex life or something don't do that
that's stupid
um but if you are
talking about like hey i'm really
struggling with my wife and you've got a
group of guys that you trust and that's
safe and aren't going to be like yeah
bro but is well tell us more about that
man what's going on
it's really important and it's not about
her it's about me processing how i'm
relating to her and so i don't get my
feelings heard about it i'm glad that
she's got a place to go talk about us
and talk about me and talk about herself
and talk about how she's processing
things
um she said that she has worked very
hard to disconnect her responses
from my energy
and that's really important
she made a great statement she said your
energy your highs and your lows and your
stun gun energy
that's your issue not hers
and initially i was a lot and so she
would try to match my a lot and then
when i was low she would try to match
the low
even if she's having a great day
now over the past few years she's
learned
she's worked really hard and it's pretty
amazing actually because it untethers me
too in a great way i'll come home really
kind of low
that doesn't mean that she has to have a
bad day
i can't be a jerk about it but i can say
man i had a rough day at work or this
happened or i really had a hard call out
to deal with or somebody was struggling
she can continue doing what she's doing
back i'm sorry that you experienced that
without it her taking that on that's
because that's not her job the other
side i can come home and be like
let's go do this
and she can say well we still have to
get this stuff done and this stuff done
because she doesn't have to wear that
energy either and so disconnecting has
been really important so i would
challenge everybody listening
where are you absorbing other people's
energy in your life and trying to make
it yours
and disconnecting yourself from that is
important or where is somebody trying to
force their energy onto you
i'm sad you got to be sad with me you
can't smile and still be sad or the
other way i'm in a great mood why are
you so sad well because i'm just happy
to be sad you can be in a great mood and
i can be sad and it doesn't mean we're
broken that means we're just having
different experiences
um
she's also
very even keel and you know you tend to
marry your opposite and um she's pretty
even keel and she gardens and she writes
and she doesn't go on every ride with me
meaning when i'm like it's all coming
down let's fill up the freezers she'll
say oh okay if you want to fill the
freezers up you're welcome to do that um
i i'm not really going to home depot
right now to buy another freezer um i
got some stuff i'm going to do but if
you need to go do that that's great or
if i'm like it's all great let's go buy
a bunch of what she's like let's let's
look at the budget let's don't go buy a
bunch of stuff right so all to say is
she doesn't go on all the rides with me
anymore
and um i don't go on the rides with her
and that allows us to
not use each other's energy to keep
stupid cycles running they tend to blow
themselves out pretty quick
and she also said that she's not
codependent um my highs and lows don't
have to be her highs and lows and vice
versa i'll often also say to two both of
our horns we're not abusive to one
another i don't force her into my lows
or into my highs and vice versa
um she also is super hardcore about
routine
i run so hard um i just go and go and go
and go and go last night is a perfect
example
i thought i had been drugged i collapsed
at 7 15. p.m
like out out
and we got two little kids and so what
she has learned is a when john collapses
which happens once every few months
um it's not because he doesn't want to
be plugged in it's not because he hates
me or the kids or doesn't care about my
feelings
and usually we'll have talked about on
thursday wednesday thursday friday i'm
going to need you full full presence and
i'll i can figure that out but when i
collapse
um
bedtimes are still gonna happen because
she's got this routine built in or when
she collapses i know bedtimes are gonna
happen
also when i come home and i'm like hey
let's have a water balloon fight on the
roof and then shave the dog and then
spray paint each other that'd be so fun
she's able to go with us
and the kids are like ah
and then we're gonna do bedtime and
we're gonna do bath and we're gonna do
bedtime and the routine is gonna help
tether the family and so there's some
days that we kind of bend the routine
one way or a bit at the other but
it stays put and so those are the ways
that she tells me she deals with my
highs and lows i didn't know i had any i
didn't know i had any i know that um how
do you all deal with my highs and lows
it's a great question
you know that's something i'm still
figuring out
beyond i had an admin one time at one of
the universities i worked at and our
desks backed up to each other and i
didn't know this but she said i used she
used to
when people called by candy to get a
meeting and you go talk to him and go
see him right away
she said i knew by the music you were
listening to because i could hear it
through the wall like yeah today's not a
good day let's schedule this for
tomorrow and i didn't even know she's
like i just knew you well enough to know
this isn't gonna be a good day for the
meeting will not be productive in this
person's favor let's we should probably
go i didn't know that was even happening
right
um one thing that i've had to do is
figure out is whatever your if it's a
low is it something that
that i can help with or that concerns
the show
you know and if not
then i can't take that on
gotcha but you do
i think we have mutual trust enough
where you can say hey you're thinking
about something else i need you here
right and then i can then that's about
being professional and like being a good
steward of the show right then you show
up and you smile and you get it going
right you get it done
right i agree with that what about when
i'm i guess you can tamp it down pretty
well you're pretty good at that
you can bring my energy down by just
looking at me with your kelly look huh
thanks
[Laughter]
ben
like you're relatively new to the board
what does it feel like
if i can be a lot you know
i i tend to be like a
i'm sort of an empath so i kind of feel
the highs of other people i kind of feel
the lows of other people
but i'm also like a very peacekeeping
type so i try not to
like externalize that so i try to make
everyone feel comfortable and stuff
so i just push it down whatever
craziness you're dealing with i just
push it down
just shove it down i want to pretend
it's not there and jenna you carry a
flask with you at all times oh yeah you
know that's what i'm known for around
here exactly just having a flashlight
thanks for getting hard things are
getting hard there's jenna yep drinking
it away
how do you handle it when i come in hot
i don't i don't know i feel like maybe i
i i do one of two things i can either
match somebody's energy
or i can do kind of what ben does where
i'm just like uh whatever just push down
just kind of staying level-headed
neutral
depends on my mood i need some level
head around me yeah
that's usually pretty good
huh
but i'm not mean though right ah i don't
try to be mean no never okay
i would be mad at myself if i was mean
that make me sad
all right good
actually i'm super mean sarah just edits
it all out to make me look lovely
he abuses us constantly
[Laughter]
ah
i love it